Eddie Murphy is one of those names that
everybody knows and for good reason he
brought a major sequel to fruition 33
years after the first film came out well
I be damn look who to come up in here he
thinks his major box office hit haunted
mansion was not that great and continues
to transcend every major movie genre
let's talk about it candy can Lane is
Eddie Murphy's first ever holiday movie
so the bar is set super high as far as
creativity goes He reunited with
director Reginald hudin and producer
Brian graser filmmakers he hasn't worked
with since his movie Boomerang in
1992 now we are family guys living in
Los Angeles and we both love Christmas
so once again we are making a movie that
truly reflects where we are in our lives
and it shows in the work Reginald didn't
want to reveal too much but in an
interview with people he graced us with
a bit of a teaser for the upcoming
family holiday film I'm I can say
confidently you've never seen a holiday
movie like this we have jump scares car
chases and Kung Fu Fighting plus all the
holiday feels so we know Eddie Murphy is
a comedy genius whether he's setting up
Enchanted Christmas lights or hanging
around a haunted mansion there's
something really fun about putting Eddie
Murphy in a big haunted house he did a
lot of improv for this movie and nobody
really knew what to expect from him
although everybody loved his performance
he wasn't really too sold on it now when
it came time to cast for the reboot he
took it upon himself to respectfully
decline I did a Haunted Mansion movie
and it wasn't very good so I don't know
if they want to bring the old baggage
and have me stinking up the new one it's
crazy how a film that grossed $ 117
million worldwide is considered not very
good Through The Eyes of Eddie Murphy
okay well when looking at the box office
of the runchy comedy Coming to America
which ended up becoming a cult classic
garnering so much love from fans that it
got a sequel 33 years later it's clear
why Eddie would think Haunted Mansion
didn't fit the bill coming to America
generated a whopping $350 million
worldwide at the box office this was
also the beginning of Eddie Murphy and
Areno Hall's lifelong friendship every
since then we've been doing
this at clubs all over the country an
interesting fact you might not know
about the movie is that they were forced
by Paramount to cast a white person in
it
so it was like we have to have a white
person we can't do it has to be a white
person in the movie so they were trying
to think of the coolest funniest white
guy they knew and it ended up being Lou
Anderson Lou was really funny and it was
like we got to have a white guy can't
have Lou be perfect this is the first
biopic Eddie Murphy has ever starred in
he got to play one of his real life
Heroes Rudy Raymore he's an underground
comedian from the 1970s who is known for
his ex-rated comedy style when Eddie
first approached Rudy Ray about the
movie Rudy had no interest in being
involved at all he had no interest in
making a movie he was like let's go on
tour together he wanted to tour and he
wanted to be in the movies still though
he finds Rudy's confidence in his work
even though it was considered so
off-the-wall so inspiring that he felt
the story needed to be told that's the
most important thing is believing in
your stuff if you believe in it whatever
it is that's the most important
ingredient you truly can't say Eddie
Murphy doesn't transcend genres if
you've seen the action movie 48 hours
though yes he still managed to be cute
and funny but otherwise his role was
quite serious I thought it would be hip
while everybody was saying is we know
wait when when I do my movie to be a
comedy to come out and do a serious
picture it's also quite impressive that
he had nothing dramatic or serious in
his portfolio at the time before taking
on the role it was helpful that he was
working with Walter Hill because he was
able to lean on his direction if you're
in a catatonic State Walter can go in
the editing room and make make people
make you win Awards all right now we
have to talk about the most iconic
donkey in all of Animation history wow
only a true friend would be that truly
honest Eddie Murphy was absolutely
iconic in the Shrek franchise and he
attributes it all to his Instinct as an
actor I'm not technically as much as I
am instinctive as an actor and I bring
that to whatever I'm doing he doesn't
really do a lot of research or study his
characters a lot when he performs he
just goes with his gut and often just
Nails it every time how would dunky's
voice really s how can I get in my voice
you
know so we've got action comedy drama
animation family films and even musicals
Eddie Murphy sir what can't you do even
though he's obviously an amazing
performer he was super insecure about
his performance when it came to Dream
Girls every time I'm going running to
the monor afterwards and be like is did
you could you keep some of that okay
well obviously they only take the best
of the best out of the million takes
they do and he says the outtakes are
probably hysterical people describe him
being in this role as a huge risk for
his career you know people come to see
me in comedies you know and I'm coming
this a big long stretch from you know
Daddy Daycare to this what do you think
did he nail it after pouring through his
filmography it's obvious to me that
Eddie Murphy truly is the Jack of ultra
raes he's been in the business for
decades cracking jokes emulating icons
and dropping that touch of humor in
films that are otherwise majorly intense
what's your favorite Eddie Murphy movie